bonsoir mesdames messieurs ici bernard
de rome de 1970 eh oui et voici votre
bulletin de nouvelles de 2000 mètres une
campagne publicitaire lancée pour le 50e
anniversaire de loto québec a fait
beaucoup parler d'elle la semaine
dernière ici surtout grâce à son porte
parole
ce jeune bernard de rome de 1970 qui a
été ramené à nous grâce à une hyper
trucage qu'on appelle en anglais d'une
digue fake
produit par la firme montréalaise sid
lee martin gauthier président de sid lee
montréal chef mondial des opérations de
l'entreprise bonsoir martin gauthier
soir mais ses clients alors on a pu voir
dans les derniers jours les dessous de
cette publicité sur la page facebook de
loto québec expliqué brièvement comment
ça fonctionne comment on est arrivé à
crise la hausse a été évidemment une
idée des artisans de chez cédric ont
présenté le concept à loto québec et
loto québec tout de suite vu un un
potentiel publicitaire var ce concept
donc la première des choses qu'il
fallait avoir c'était le consentement de
bernard de rome donc sont allés voir
monsieur de rome et on expliquer
justement un peu les dessous de l'hyper
trucages et comment on voulait on
voulait utiliser la technologie donc la
technologie a été utilisée en gros en
prenant les images de monsieur de rome
dans ce multi nouvelles de 1970 on
insère sa à l'intérieur d'un logiciel
qui va prendre tout ou les fascias halle
de monsieur de rome et ensuite on prend
un comédien qui lui ressemblait beaucoup
avec la même carrure le même genre de
comportement 1 puis monsieur pierre
verville qui nous ont aidés parce que
c'est un bon imitateur monsieur de rome
donc tous a été mis en fin de compte le
visage a été chargée donc les yeux ni la
bouche servi de point d'ancrage pour
pour faire cette hyper trucage là et il
ne restait qu'à voir la voix de monsieur
de roms dans une salle bernard dutrey
bernard de rome qui n'a studio a
travaillé des heures et des heures pour
avoir la vraie voix par dessus
évidemment on le module est un peu pour
avoir ça
sa voix de jeunesse alors ces seules
affaires c'est qu'on arrive à recréer
carrément le bernard de rome de 1970
vous dites module est un peu ça va très
loin on est capable de de créer
carrément un personnage ou de réinventer
un personnage et de lui mettre les mots
dans la bouche
oui mais il ya encore des limites à sopi
évidemment il faut être prudent à tous
hommes ayant encore des limites parce
que c'est l'ordinateur qui recrée le
visage mais la voix n'est pas ne n'est
pas nécessairement encore après c'est
assez difficile de faire de lui par
trucage avec la voix donc c'est pour ça
que encore aujourd'hui on doit aller en
studio pourrait être en mesure d'
amalgame et les deux mais jusqu'à aller
de faire dire des choses a déjà c'est
encore possible mais évidemment il faut
utiliser les tic
oui pour pi le consentement qui est là
et le vous le faites avec le
consentement de bernard de rome pour le
tout québec
exor un produit ici donc on comprend
bien ce qui se passe
est ce que ces deux lits accepterait de
faire cela sur le plan politique ou pour
mettre un visage ou des mots dans la
bouche d'une autre personne à des fins
politiques jamais nous nous chez ces
deux lions frère on ferait jamais ça
parce qu'on le cycle 1 ce n'est pas
éthique et deuxièmement nous avons une
charte chez sid lee qui ne sut qui ne
suivraient pas les règles que vous venez
de le dire donc le consentement est
essentiel ça c'est une des choses
et deuxièmement on est toujours celle du
che séderie s'il n'y a pas de oui c'est
non donc ça prend un oui pour avoir
accepté mais un consentement sinon on ne
le fait pas est ce que bernard derome
est rémunéré pour sa wii donc maintenant
les rameurs parole de loto québec c'est
à dire qu'avec on ad on est des ententes
avec lui des à mort de rome a été payé
le comédien était payé tout le monde a
été payé parce qu'on ne veut pas non
plus on ne veut pas non plus avoir ce
qu'on appelle d'essayer d'avoir des fake
personnes donc être prudent dit fe nou
lé pa trucage on
on ne rémunère et tout le monde tout le
monde s'entend bien là dessus tout le
monde a donné son accord sa demande
quelle somme d'investissement en temps
en argent c'est complexe faire ça pour
ses pas pour violon plex qu'une
publicité dite traditionnelle c'est pas
plus compliqué sauf que la technologie
est au soutien de la création
donc on a utilisé cette technologie le
et ça ne veut pas dire il ya des gens
qui me demandent est ce que vous allez
réutiliser sa cette technologie dans le
futur si encore une fois cette
technologie leur soutien à une idée
créative que nous allons avoir la
réponse est oui mais sinon nous on aime
innover gc10 on aime créer on l'a déjà
fait une fois donc on va sûrement
utiliser d'autres technologies pour
d'autres choses d'autres concepts
est-ce que ça ça vous donne une
visibilité exceptionnelle à
l'international parce que déjà c'est de
lier rendu à l'extérieur du québec
s'initie mais s'est rendu à l'extérieur
est ce que ça devient une carte de
visite comme nous avons déjà ce qu'on
appelle le partage a été partagée sur
plusieurs parts sur plusieurs
plateformes de réseaux sociaux
donc évidemment ça nous donne une belle
visibilité maintenant vous avez raison
on a notre siège social ici à montréal
avec plus de 500 artisans mais on
rayonne à travers le monde à travers
londres paris new york toronto seattle
et los angele avec plus de mille
artisans qui travaillaient pour ces deux
lits maintenant donc ce ne se mêlent
fierté pour nous puis évidemment
remercié loto québec de nous avoir donné
la chance de produire ce parce que de
faire revivre bernard de rome
vous serez d'accord avec moi que c'était
c'est quelque chose de facile alors fait
de faire revivre bernard qui vit
toujours voilà le bernard de 1979 et oui
tout à fait de faire revenir à revivre
et si ça vous avez raison merci beaucoup
martin gauthier merci mais cette soirée